[Música]
i
mi primera experiencia laboral la tuve a
los 20 años tuve la suerte de conseguir
empleo en una de las empresas más
prestigiosas de la ciudad de posadas
habíamos ingresado yo y otras 19
personas durante la firma del contrato
el gerente general de la firma nos dice
muchachos les felicito acaban de
conseguir empleo en la empresa en la que
se van a jubilar y estábamos nosotros
con una especie de mariposa en el
estómago algunos lloraban otros estaban
festejando de aguantar los familiares
bueno
firmamos el contrato nos fuimos a una
especie de capacitación de que euro dos
meses y de ahí nos mandaron a cada uno
de nuestro sector correspondiente yo en
lo personal súper desenvolverme muy bien
en el área que me tocó iba todo perfecto
trabajaba ganaba mi dinero fin de mes un
muy buen muy buen dinero inclusive me
sobraba
pasado el tiempo de un día para el otro
las cosas comenzaron a cambiar en la
empresa la empresa tuvo un déficit
económico y se vio obligada a producir
de otra manera a reducir los horarios
cambió la mano de obra de un país a otro
y así de un día para el otro fue como yo
y esos otros 19 5 que entramos
terminamos perdiendo trabajo seguro
entonces me quedo una sola cosa una cosa
clara el trabajo seguro lo único seguro
del trabajo seguro es que seguro te
corren si las cosas van mal seguro te
corren y así fue como acabé perdiendo mi
trabajo yo estaba desconcertado no sabía
qué hacer pensé que fue un error y que
todo se iba a acomodar media noble mi
trabajo hacer el pse que fue un error de
ellos nada más ha visto yo nunca había
faltado siempre cumplir supe
desempeñarme bien fui el primero que
salió a la capacitación estaba en una
situación muy similar a la de
no sé si alguna usted leyó el libro
quien sea rodó mi caso o quien sea
comida mi caso bueno para los que no lo
han leído el libro habla de dos
ratoncitos que vienen en un laberinto y
de un día para el otro les dejan de
poner el queso en donde dos donde le
daban de comer y uno de los ratoncitos
dice ah no ha caído que eso acá siempre
había queso así que tiene que volver a
ver que eso yo me voy a quedar sentado
acá que me vuelvan a poner el queso y el
otro ratoncito dice bueno no dejaron de
poner el queso yo voy a salir del
laberinto voy a ir en otro lado porque
no me quiero morir de hambre y así fue
como hizo mientras el otro ratoncito se
quedó en el grito esperando el terminó
muriendo de hambre
yo hice exactamente lo contrario con los
ahorros que tenía
decidí irme a vivir a brasil exactamente
al balneario camboriú también mi
empresita reales y no fui a buscar una
vía mejorada al llegar me alquilo una
especie de pausada es como una especie
de hostel
consiguió un empleo en el que pagaban
por comisión allá es muy fácil no seguir
empleo por venta entonces comisionada
tenía una vida medianamente tranquila me
alcanzada para comer lo que lo quería un
día volviendo del trabajo pasó por una
hora en construcción y me llama la
atención de que veo que los albañiles a
los servicios pedreros que los pedreros
fabricaban los ladrillos en el mismo
lugar donde estaban trabajando es decir
pensaban los ladrillos y a los tres días
levantaban la pared me llamó mucho la
atención porque no emanaba ningún tipo
de humo nos emanaba en gases tóxicos no
hacían ruido eran los silenciosos me
pareció algo muy moderno al otro día al
salir del trabajo voy y me entrevistó
con los pedreros y me cuentan que son
los ladrillos ecológicos los ladrillos
ecológicos son los ladrillos que evitan
el horno a combustión para su fraguado
es decir evitan la tala de millones de
árboles que se utilizan para ayudar los
hornos evitar el humo contaminante que
emanan esos hornos y evitar la
desertificación de nuestro suelo yo me
quedé muy contento con eso me encantó la
idea y dije bueno yo tengo que poner
estos misiones porque emisiones todavía
existen obreros y yo quiero modificar
esto quiero
esto mi provincia quiero poner en marcha
la idea de emprender me volví a misiones
con los ahorros que tenía presentar mi
proyecto desde una entidad financiera
pude conseguir el dinero y me traje la
máquina de geológicos los primeros
ensayos pero hay error no me salían se
me rompían busco una especie de apoyo
emocional en un ingeniero y me dice
rodrigo que te dedicabas y no yo
anteriormente estaba trabajando brasil
como vendedor me dice zapatero su zapato
busque quiere ni hacer ladrillos y no
tenía la menor idea como es hacer el
ladrillo y me tiró un poquito para abajo
pero la realidad es que me sirvió para
tomar más impulso buscar interna
información y poder o sea me di cuenta
que en córdoba existía una red de
fabricantes de ladrillos ecológicos de
cual se brindaban apoyo mutuo entre
ellos me tomó el colectivo está córdoba
en villa carlos paz me entrevistó con
los fabricantes ladrillos ecológicos me
brindan toda la capacitación y así volví
a misiones y porque todo lo que
aprendiera para fabricar los ladrones
salieron excelentes me salieron
perfectos
a la hora de buscar mi primeras ventas
noté que había muchísima gente
interesada en los medios de comunicación
me ayudaron muchísimo difundieron mi
idea y eso generó interés en la gente
sobre todo por lo sustentable pero qué
pasa me tenía que enfrentar al perjuicio
de la gente decir bueno yo fabrico
la división ecológico que lo primero que
pensó a la gente es que eran ladrillo
hecho de hojitas seca y ramita y que el
a ponerlos e ibaka de nuestra casa la
realidad es que no era así entonces en
córdoba habían dicho que la facultad de
ingeniería realizaba un ensayo de
compresión de los ladrillos es decir una
prensa los apretaba y decía cuánto podía
soportar de compresión a la hora de
construir
yo digo bueno voy a mandarlos los dos
ejemplares que tengo para ensayar no
saber qué dice si son buenos no son
buenos y ladrillos de paso eso va a
respaldar todas mis palabras me voy
corriendo la terminal porque yo digo
bueno voy a cerrar mis venta mi primera
venta necesito este respaldos lo mando
ya la terminal me voy a la empresa de
transporte llegó corriendo a la terminal
y la gente almería un gendarme me dice
que tenéis ahí yo tenía una cajita un
tipo de zapatos donde con los ladrillos
lo envolví lo pueden volver en una cinta
adhesiva similar a los paquetes y
marihuana no ciertas y yo le di dos son
dos ladrillos ecológicos así ecológico y
para acá me dice me dé
me llevo una piecita ms gusta muy bien
mirado pero son pensados así bueno vamos
a romperla
la siguiente que estaba envuelto y le
sorprende unos ladrillos para ser unos
plásticos pero más grande lo cierto y
dice ah mira bueno lo mandan un ensayo
para ver si tenía droga no tenía droga
no tenía droga hasta hoy en día yo me
sigo riendo de esa anécdota los mandos
los ladridos necesario de compresión me
dan como resultado que son ladrillos
clase a que soportan el doble de
compresión que un ladrillo convencional
o sea son los mejores ladrido que así
fue como pude concretar mis primeras
ventas a transmisiones hoy por hoy la
empresa tiene una producción diaria de 5
mil ladrillos pude generar cuatro
puestos genuinos de trabajo de cual
dependen cuatro familias
y así fue cómo cambió mi vida de un día
para el otro sin querer yo me fui a
buscar futuro en otro lado terminé
volviendo con una idea innovadora
si pudiera decir cuáles fueron los dos
pilares que me permitieron a mí llevar a
cabo este emprendimiento el primero fue
la educación financiera
la educación financiera es aprender a
ser empresario educación financiera es
aprender a ser emprendedor es aprender a
hacer que el dinero trabaje para
nosotros es crear empleo es crear
progreso es educación financiera sin
duda el otro pilar fundamental para
llevar a cabo un emprendimiento es la
innovación la innovación
yo puede crear mi propio concepto
innovación innovación es estar siempre
un paso adelantado a los demás la
innovación es el motor que impulsa el
cambio las empresas sin duda la
innovación es el ingrediente clave para
una receta sea exitosa para que una
empresa sea exitosa
esa es mi humilde experiencia espero que
les haya servido algo muchas gracias
a